what y'all think about uh yeah poor
portnoy i think this is further proof
portney is going to be president
whoa
let's go
whoa okay let's break down the story
real quick okay so dave portnoy uh head
of bar stool there was a four thousand
word piece uh uh written uh by somebody
at the business insider right business
insider is essentially like um
like a patreon i guess for uh it's like
a
business it's like buzzfeed for money
yeah but you have to there's nothing
wrong with being behind a paywall
patreon.com
i'm not going to hate on that but
essentially they wrote a a hit piece
about him saying that there are women
that were coming out and they said that
he was having like extremely violent sex
with them they wrote this piece and they
had these women come out there's a
couple girls that was mentioned this uh
this girl madison uh started uh
messaging him over like text and
snapchat the messages got explicit
apparently he sent videos of him [ __ ]
to her uh she says that she has like a a
rape fantasy uh you know uh porno flies
her out to his house this is all alleged
he films her while uh she's blowing them
uh they have sex
she claims it was too rough said uh said
it was a too much yeah she slept on the
couch that night portnoy says that it
was all consensual they disagreed about
everything after having sex and that's
why she slept on the couch yeah uh
madison texts her friend a few couple
few days later saying it felt like uh
she was being raped yeah and what porno
basically said with this is this this is
he said she said this is not true he
says it's not true at all she says i
guess it is and then we gotta figure
that out and a little extra detail for
the couch thing is that was after a few
weeks like he was like we talked for a
few weeks after having sex couldn't
agree on anything and one of those
nights she slept on the couch it wasn't
even like the same night it was just
like we had sex we have nothing in
common nothing we're still trying to
make it work it's not happening and she
wanted to have sex that night again and
he was like we're not gonna have sex we
don't agree on anything and then she
slept on the couch i'm pretty sure
that's what he said in his statement and
then there's allison uh basically uh she
said that her friends put her up to
messaging portnoy she wanted to bring
friends for the first time uh they were
to meet and port and i said it would be
weird for them to have friends there if
they're gonna be having sex uh they
don't meet up then they meet up she says
they have sex he spat on her uh choked
her she felt like she was a preyed on
and uh then took a selfie with poornoy
and her leaving his house
like so i guess that picture starts
circulating she feels suicidal and
depressed the mother finds out her
mother finds out uh and starts going
after point pornoi portnoy releases dms
of him and allison talking after um you
know he says miss my dick yet she goes
hahaha of course she replies uh allison
herself has said that it's uh not sexual
assault
uh so it seems like the mom was kind of
really stirring these things up to
protect her daughter maybe she felt like
her daughter was would obviously hurt i
didn't know allison had said that
because i do know she said she felt
suicidal and depressed three days later
and then the mom says she went to the
police police say they have no record of
maybe called the police but police say
they have no record of anything
yeah and porno basically uh shared some
texts or like dms between him and the
girl okay so really interesting thing uh
here
um obviously we don't know who's telling
the truth
um
there's really no way for us to know
yeah right so we can't really speculate
on what the truth is but we can talk
about how it's being handled and an
interesting thing that we saw from
portnoy is he went straight at the
business insider yep they tried to uh
you know assault his character is that
the term assault my character yeah i
guess yeah yeah and uh assassinate his
character assassinate yeah
assault
and uh and they tried to assassinate his
character so he immediately goes at the
writer he goes at the ceo of the
business insider who apparently is this
guy who uh got like kicked out of wall
street you know the sec said that um he
had like these securities violations and
he's a real scumbag also there's some
people that like
might have shorted the penn stock pen as
this gaming company that uh there's a
gambling company that he's partnered up
with barstool it dropped 20 once the
story came out now also they didn't meet
certain quarterly earnings projections
they thought they would so that was part
of the drop right it wasn't just because
of that but uh an interesting thing is
that he started he went on the attack
right and if you really want to talk
about like cancel culture and cancellers
the canceled culture fight is not really
from
the
talent working within corporations
perspective okay so like when people are
like
dave chappelle is fighting cancel
culture
it's not really dave's fight right
because dave gets paid
netflix if they choose to keep the
special on right is fighting back
against cancer culture but once dave has
put out the work
there's nothing yeah right to fight
yeah right like so
portnoy is an interesting position
because he is the corporation he is
barstool yes he's choosing to fight back
now he's also fighting for his brand
he's fighting for his livelihood right
right like of course he has to fight but
this is a good example of going i don't
care
what these brands are saying i don't
care what's going on i'm going to push
back i'm not going to apologize for this
i'm going to push back and i'm going to
fight for
the the you know to stop this
cancellation if you will right i'm
innocent and i'm going all out right
it's on some 50 cent [ __ ] you know if
you [ __ ] with 50 cent he's exposing
everything yeah and it seems like that's
portnoy's approach and what's really
interesting about that approach is
you switch the conversation from did he
rape these girls to is this a hit piece
right it used to be did he rape these
girls now the conversation is
this is a hit piece by the business
insider they charge a monthly
subscription if you really cared about
these women you would put this out
publicly wouldn't you want to stop
somebody who's out here assaulting women
but no you're going to charge for the
information about someone who's
assaulted women they did the same thing
with david dobrik
like they put a article about him in the
vlog squad there was like an alleged
sexual assault like rape charges yeah
against in that crew yeah and they put
that [ __ ] behind a paywall as well and
it's like who do you really help
like who is the predator here like if
you want to help these women wouldn't
you put this information out in the
world right yeah like why do you need to
pay to know who the alleged rapist is
yeah and also tim dillon had a release a
screenshot of someone dming him said hey
business insider asked me to write an
article about you but i stepped away
because it became clear was a hit piece
so there tim dillon is getting people
telling him they're trying to get me to
write a hit piece about you and i've
also heard that these are like guns for
hire business insider like it's easy to
like get an article written in the
business inside uh okay okay um quick
question do you know if that hurt david
dobrik's brand a lot because it seems to
me like it did it's over i don't think
it's over but it did affect it but it
hurt that app that he was like he had an
app apparently that was yeah it [ __ ]
his money up for him
the smartest thing you can do to
monetize on youtube now that's [ __ ]
going to kill him it's over the the
smartest thing you can do in these
situations is what portnoy did which is
the direct response and i don't know if
lawyers tell you not to say anything but
i know it helps when you start it by
saying my lawyers are telling me not to
say anything but here goes and then you
get to tell your entire story
uninterrupted for uh 12 minutes whatever
i did yeah yeah so now you just get all
of your side out they wrote a article
that takes six minutes to read you get
to rebut it for 12 minutes yeah and
nobody can interrupt it and i think
that's the best move whereas a lot of
these actor types or whatever probably
david drawbrook is gonna be like yeah i
don't know i just i'll just keep quiet
trust people this motherfucker's like
nope let's fire back and he got the
barbs
he got the bar stool bar yeah yeah he
does the barstool [ __ ] rock
with portnoy yeah to the end of days so
if he goes hey cancel insider or
whatever he'd be what it was like oh you
won't cancel me no we're gonna cancel
y'all yeah and then that [ __ ] starts
trending and what's really interesting
is it it basically sets a tone it's like
if you're gonna do it it was very easy
back in the day to just write an article
right right you can write an article
about any actor or that kind of stuff
and they can't really fight back yeah
but if you write an article about
portnoy and your name is on that article
it's not an anonymous article be ready
for smoke yeah that's what he's saying
you wouldn't call me a rapist we are
gonna make sure you are infamous this
blodget guy the guy who's the ceo of
business insider is
the laughingstock of barcelona and the
whole community is gonna devour that
[ __ ] yeah because at the end of
the day he's the one responsible actors
are gonna be like well i'm sorry if she
misunderstood maybe i misunderstood and
porno was like nah [ __ ] you [ __ ] them
hit him up with tupac hit him up yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] you as a whole crew whatever
it is let's go
yeah dude that's it it was a
well-handled move and this is why i have
good yeah i just i just think it's funny
i love the fact that he's fighting back
against the cancel culture [ __ ] that
being said like our boy francis ellis
was fired from barcelona for a mistake
yeah i had that thought too like he
literally made a mistake so like i need
to know where that same energy is like
yeah when it comes to the people that
are expendable yeah and that's that's
what that's when you really know you're
fighting back against cancer culture
it's like if someone expendable is
canceled and you're just like yeah you
tell them like yo you gotta you resign
that's a good point that's a really
great point you know so it's like don't
it's not like a fight against cancer
culture it's a fight to save your life
yeah you don't want the scarlet letter
yeah
yeah rapist that's done it's over yeah
you have to fight you gotta fight you
ain't got choice you know i want to
fight back against cancer culture nah
fam and you know if you don't sell
pizzas
you can't be a rapist you know what i
thought i had is i'm more inclined to
believe him because we've already seen
that video of what kind of sex he
normally has so if that's normal sex for
you i think if you're well you got that
much to lose you have to be 1 000 sure
it's all consensual beforehand i think i
mean it's definitely possible to abuse
the power but i also can see you a guy
like that being like i need to get proof
that all of this is consensual yeah
so i i tend to believe somebody who has
sex like that normally is probably gonna
make sure it's all consensual yeah he's
got his safe words and all that so risky
it's such aggressive like violent sex
yeah that it's a anybody saying
i was raped look i have marks on my neck
or some [ __ ] you probably do the guy had
a [ __ ] dog collar on you yank it on
you know what i mean like
so you yeah
you just bring up in a spur of a moment
you're saying yeah and like you're gonna
make sure like look i'm doing some [ __ ]
that could be easily perceived if i'm
not a thousand percent sure she's with
it and then she might not she might be
very not with it very not with it so i
got to make sure i get a yes on at every
step yeah like i at least that's what i
thought giving him some credit i also
had the thought of a guy who can beat a
me too this many times
that's president doug yes president
trump
i knew trump i should have known trump
was going to win when grabbing by the
[ __ ] didn't take him down yeah or grab
her by the [ __ ] that didn't destroy him
yeah it's important away buddy it's not
he don't give a [ __ ] he's untouchable
now here's the question does a guy like
that end up having a similar fate to
trump
where it becomes so divisive and there's
so many people that are against you and
angry at you just because you are you
that it becomes hard to function as
president or even as somebody it could
but one thing he does differently than
trump trump doesn't explain things
oh and and poor noi
explained everything's a good salesman
so if you're a moderate you can get with
that easier than you can with trump
trump is a little bit tough to get with
because he won't explain the [ __ ] he's
just like nah that's how i feel [ __ ] you
if you don't agree yeah that's cool
that's gonna win a lot of people portnoy
will say that but also explain yeah this
is how i feel here's why i feel this way
yeah i mean the dude might be
uncancelable
drop the m-bomb mad accusations i mean
it's insane nothing sticks nothing still
hustling to pizzas that weekend he was
like yo we and i think he donated 350k
like they sold 50 000 pizzas because
they're doing this like um
what is it called at home pizza or
whatever it is like the frozen pizzas
frozen pizza whatever yeah
and uh
they sold like 50 000 of them this
weekend i think maybe they were in
walmart for the first time this weekend
and they sold 50 000 he's like i'm
donating 350 thousand dollars to the
barstool fund this is the fun that like
helps oh yeah yeah yeah yeah boss move
yeah made all the money on the [ __ ]
pizzas he knows exactly and people are
going to go out and support you extra
they're going to buy the pizza just
because they don't like the cancelers
it's like the goya beans thing yes yes
exactly yes right so it's like
anti-cancel marketing is a very powerful
form of marketing i don't think he's
uncancelable i just think his audience
is predominantly like young white
fraternity college kids yes and all the
allegations brought against them whether
it's like the n-word thing sexual
misconduct that's a good point like if
he starts going off on trump and he's
like yo [ __ ] trump or whatever i think
all of a sudden the pen stock dips a lot
more oh wait go on that what do you
think just because like he interviewed
trump and like that got great reviews
yeah and like he's like catering to an
audience and i think the audience is
predominantly like college age white
kids
and
things like oh sexual misconduct where
there's not a perfect allegation but
there's a story he said she said yeah i
think they're willing to look past that
in large numbers
if it's like if his whole audience is
women i think this thing comes down to
him a lot harder if his audience is
predominantly black and he says downward
i think that comes down on him a lot
harder
you